hi this is nina nesbitt and this is my
glamour festival for life
[Applause]
my formula for a cracking tick tock
musical
is find an issue i've done a lot about
fat boys because i think it is a real
big issue at the moment
especially during lockdown i kind of did
it as a bit of a joke
and then it turned into like a bit of a
thing my daily mantra
is now this sounds really morbid but i'm
gonna die
one day it's inevitable for all of us
we're all gonna die
enjoy your life while you're here make
the most of it stop caring about
these little things just live your best
life
i definitely have waves when it comes to
my mental
health some weeks and months i'm feeling
on top of the world really confident
and then other months i'm a complete
mess
so i think yeah just sitting through it
riding through it
and knowing that it will pass is
actually weirdly comforting
music has helped me deal with a lot i
had terrible anxiety as a teenager and
music was the only thing that really
came me down it's definitely like a form
of
therapy for me it's also taking me
around the world which is
amazing the one thing i couldn't live
without i want to say my phone
because i'm addicted to it and that's
really embarrassing but it's true
actually i would quite like to live
without my phone but
unfortunately my job doesn't let that
happen
best thing that i've learned this year
is probably
that everyone's been having weird
breakdowns on social media including
myself i just think i was way more
insecure before
the pandemic i really struggled with
failure
as a young kid and i think it was the
root of a lot of my anxiety
problems i put this insane amount of
pressure on myself
to succeed and exceed
expectations all the time i don't know
what it's i don't know what that's about
maybe i should ask my therapist i've
learned as i've got older and
experienced failure
failure is actually a huge
blessing because without failure there's
no success
do you know what i mean you don't know
what success is without
failing the quirkiest thing i've done in
the name of wellness
one time on tour i was in oregon i went
to this like
really strange um cult
village it's like a cult community the
ubers weren't allowed to pick us up
there there was no ubers
anything like that it was all very much
like
off the grid it was a great spa day
and i would recommend it to anyone the
best piece of advice i've ever been
given is by my boyfriend
it's quite a funny one but i think i
apply it to anything in life
writing a song is a lot like doing a
fart
if you have to force it it's probably
[ __ ] and i think
that i apply that to anything in life if
anything feels forced or unnatural
or just not authentic you shouldn't be
doing it
i feel trust myself
when i come home at the end of the day
and i take my makeup
off put my hair up on top of my head put
my trackies on and sit down on the sofa
and binge watch anything that's on tv
my relationship mantra you
never lose with love because
either you're with the person you're
supposed to be with it's all going great
and you're winning
or things have gone to [ __ ] and they've
broken up you your heart's broken
whatever it is you feel like [ __ ]
but you're still winning because you're
not supposed to be with that person
and they've actually done your favor in
the long run because you're going to go
and meet
someone even better my instant mood
booster whenever i'm
doubting myself i put on bill's bills
bills
by destiny's child because it's just an
absolute banger